-Jude Law.
You look great, buddy!
-Hello. Welcome to my home.
-Thank you so --
Oh.
-Welcome.
-I'm in your home. See?
Like it or not.
I always knew I'd get an invite.
[ Laughs ]
-I've got to ask.
So, all these people
you've been interviewing,
you've sat in their houses.
Are you getting, like,
different sort of insight?
Are people, like, super-relaxed
suddenly and just slipping up?
Or have they got, like,
a glass of wine next to them?
-Yeah, that's happened
a few times, yeah.
A couple times
where they had a --
-We're going to have
peachy moments.
-The beard is for -- Are you
filming "Fantastic Beasts" now?
-I just started.
We were meant to start --
I was meant to start on the day
I believe London
went into lockdown.
So we were all prepped,
sets built,
everyone ready to go,
rehearsals done, and --
-Wow.
-We all went into our various
lockdown states.
And so I've just been waiting.
There were several moments
I kept thinking,
"Ah, you know, maybe I'll just
shave it off, grow it again."
But I couldn't go through
the two-week burn, you know?
-Oh, I know that.
There's that two weeks
where it's just so itchy.
-It's awful.
The hairs all grow in.
The hairs all start
just going in.
-I always have a weird
couple red hairs.
Do you have that or no?
-I'll tell you what I do have,
since last time
I played Dumbledore,
I have a lot more gray hair,
that's for sure.
[ Speaking indistinctly ]
You know, growing it back, yes.
So then I'm like, "Wow.
They're not going to have to
put anything in there.
That's all me."
-That's going to happen.
Yeah. Exactly.
That's going to happen, right?
Well, what have you been doing
with your time at home?
-I've fallen in love
with my garden.
I've realized how lucky I am
to have a garden.
And I spent -- We had
the most beautiful spring.
It was, like, the one blessing
amidst this madness.
And I've become obsessed
with my wisteria.
So, wisteria, if you don't know,
is a creeping flower and plant.
-Yes. It's beautiful.
-And it grows along a railing
in my garden.
And I've got a raised garden
above that.
And I sort of had this idea
that I wanted it to go up and
go along this railing, too,
so I trained down two wires,
and I literally watched
this thing grow up the wire.
And it now goes up the wire
and is growing along the top.
I'm more obsessed with that
than anything else in my life
at the moment.
My wife thinks I'm going...
-And it smells beautiful, too.
Wisteria.
-It smells great.
Oh, on top of that,
I had a baby, so there you go.
-[ Laughs ]
Bury the lead.
Bury the lead on that one.
Congrats, Dad.
-Thank you. Yeah.
-That's awesome.
-It's really wonderful.
So, we are --
Again, we feel pretty blessed
that we were in a time where we
could, as a family, you know --
Uh, we could just nest...
-Yeah.
-...and enjoy each other's
company every day as it came.
It was an unusual but kind of
enforced, you know, love-in.
-Yeah.
You know, I was thinking
about you because everyone
started renting and buying
the movie "Contagion."
It was a movie
about a global pandemic.
-Yeah.
-It was made years ago.
Is it eerie to even think
about doing that movie
now that we're kind of
living it?
-Kind of extraordinary,
isn't it?
First of all, I found it
a little odd that everyone
went back to watch that in
the middle of the real thing.
-Yeah.
-It was like -- You're like --
You just turn on the news.
You don't need to watch it.
But at the same time, it was --
Yeah, well, first of all,
I think I wrote immediately
to Steven Soderbergh
and just said, "You got it.
You were there 10 years ago."
And if I'm honest, I remember
also one of the most --
kind of affecting memories
or experiences on that film
were the -- the doctors and the
virologists who are advising us,
all of whom were these
extraordinary men,
and they were all saying to us,
"This is a matter of when,
not if."
And I remember leaving
the whole experience thinking,
"Oh, yeah, you know --"
Look at me.
You touch yourself on the face
10,000 times a day.
We don't wash our hands.
All of that stuff
was sort of embedded in me.
But, of course,
it slowly percolates away.
And as you say,
here we are in it.
So it is kind of unusual.
-Yeah. Just bizarre.
It's just -- The whole thing
is just really bizarre.
Even -- I agree with you,
I was like -- I was guilty.
I actually rented the movie,
as well.
And I go, why -- Maybe I was
looking for hints or answers
of how it's going to end.
-Yeah, that's right.
-I was getting advice --
I was like -- "Oh, yeah.
We're living it, yeah."
The last time
you were on our show,
we talked about
"The Young Pope."
It was just out on HBO.
You told me this story. We never
got around to telling it.
But I would like you to --
Do you remember when
Vice President Joe Biden
visited you on the set?
-He did. He did. We were in --
You know, when --
A few people would come by.
And I always enjoyed meeting
them dressed as the pope.
I mean, who doesn't, right?
You walk in --
Especially when you've got
like 20 cardinals around you
and the Vatican Guard,
it's pretty big
to be in all white.
But the day he came, I think
I was shooting in the apartment,
and I was in my pajamas,
so it wasn't quite as effective.
What a charming man.
He came with -- his whole
family, if I remember,
because I remember he had
his grandchildren with him.
And he put me at ease
immediately,
because he literally -- I think
he said something like,
"It's okay. I've just
come from the real guy."
-[ Laughs ]
-And I was like, "Oh."
-"Yeah, I just left
the real pope."
-Yeah. "I met the real deal.
You're just an actor."
-[ Laughs ] I love that.
Because -- I'll remember that
story because it's so funny.
You think, "Oh, he's going to
freak out, man."
-Yeah.
-It's like being in the Vatican,
in the pope's bedroom.
And, like, what?
And he's like...
"Yeah. Just came
from the real thing.
Anyway, good to see you, kid.
Keep it up."
[ Speaking indistinctly ]
You know, like, completely --
-It couldn't have been
more boring.
-What a gentleman.
-Yeah, he's a good man.